THAT. SIX GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO TODAY'S HEARING ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW I AM
ASSEMBLY WOMAN CUDDY
PETRIE-NORRIS BEFORE WE GET
STARTED I WE WILL JUST ADDRESS A
COUPLE OF HOUSE KEEPING ITEMS ON
FIRST I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
THE ASSEMBLY HAS EXPERIENCED A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS TO
COMEDIAN FOR PROCEEDINGS OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT ALL VOICES ARE HEARD
HOWEVER CONTACT THAT DISRUPTS
AND DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT OF
THE HEARING IT. THANK YOU IN
ADVANCE- FOR YOUR COOPERATION
BUT TO ENSURE THAT MEMBERS OF
THE MEDIA AND PUBLIC HAVE ACCESS
TO OUR PROCEEDINGS TODAY THIS
HEARING WILL BE STREAMED ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S EBSITE AND MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CAN PROVIDE
TESTIMONY HERE IN PERSON IN ROOM
FOUR THIRTY SEVEN UP TO PRESERVE
THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE HERE AND
TO ENSURE THE PUBLIC ACCESS TO
THE DISCUSSION PLEASE DO FOLLOW
THE DIRECTIONS OF OUR SERGEANTS
I'M AT THE APPROPRIATE MOMENT IF
ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WITH LIKE TO TESTIFY.
PROFOUND ALL WITNESS TESTIMONY
TODAY WILL BE IN PERSON- THERE
WILL BE NO PHONE OR VIRTUAL
TESTIMONY FOR TODAY'S HEARING.
BOB WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND PROCEED AS
A SUB COMMITTEE I THERE ARE NO
AUTHORS IN THE ROOM I BELIEVE
THAT SERGEANTS ARE CALLING
AUTHORS OFFICES. SO THAT WE CAN
NOT GET THIS SHOW ON THE ROAD.
WELL I BEFORE WE JUMP INTO BILL
PRESENTATIONS I WANT TO WELCOME
OUR NEWEST COMMITTEE MEMBER LORI
WILSON I WHO IS REPRESENTING THE
ELEVENTH DISTRICT ARBOR PLEASED
TO HAVE YOU ANA ON THAT KIND OF
ABILITY COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME ON THE SCENE. AND I IT
LOOKS LIKE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
SO AS SECRETARY IF YOU CAN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PETRIE-NORRIS PRESENT PATTERSON
IFGREAT. LACKING MEDINA IT
RODRIGUEZ AND WILSON. ALL RIGHT
AS WE DO HAVE A QUORUM WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND JUMP TO
FILE ITEM NINE I AB TWENTY NINE
HUNDRED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON HI WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY NINE HUNDRED. WOULD
REQUIRE THAT THE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE MONITOR THE FINANCIAL
INFORMATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
FISCALE ANNUALLY THE FISCAL
SYSTEM HAS ALLOWED THE STATE TO
MODERNIZE HOW IT MANAGES ITS
FINANCING BY COMBINING THE
STATE'S ACCOUNTING BUDGETING
CASH MANAGEMENT OF PROCUREMENT
OPERATIONS INTO A SINGLE
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT SYSTEM.
HOWEVER AS WE ALL KNOW THIS IS
SUCH A LARGE SYSTEM THAT IS VERY
CRITICAL BUT THE STATE.
CONTINUES TO HAVE OVERSIGHT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IT'S OPERATING AS
EFFICIENTLY AS POSSIBLE THEY'VE
ALREADY BEEN WE SEEN IT IN THE
NET REPEATEDLY. NUMEROUS WIDELY
REPORTED SHORTCOMINGS OF THE
PROJECT RANGING FROM COST
INCREASES LACK OF AVAILABLE DATA
AND DELAYED TIMELINE SO IT'S
CRITICAL. TO IMPLEMENT ANNUAL
REPORTING. UP UNTIL THE PROJECT
IS COMPLETED TO ENSURE THAT FITS
CAL IS OPERATING AS INTENDED WE
NEED ANNUALLY. THE EYES OF THE
AUDITOR FOCUSED ON THIS CAL GOD
IT'S A VERY VERY SERIOUS- ISSUE
WITH THE PROBLEMS IN THE BREAK
DOWN SOME SOME DIVISIONS
DEPARTMENT CAN'T EVEN USE IT-
THERE'S BEEN WARNINGS OF. OF
SOME OF THE ACCURACY THAT'S
COMING COMING THROUGH IT IT'S A
IT'S I THINK IT'S A BIG
IMPORTANT- OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE CLEAR THAT THIS INTENTION
OF THE LEGISLATURE. THAT THAT
THAT THE AUDITOR. DO THIS
ANNUALLY TAKE A LOOK AT IT PUT
IT HIGH ON THE LEVEL. OF REVIEW
UP BECAUSE IT'S SO SIGNIFICANT
IMPORTANT AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER ABOUT. THE BILL. AND I DO
BELIEVE YOU HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES NO GENUINE SWEETHEART-
THERE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AT ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WAS WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT- AB TWO NINE ZERO ZERO.
C. NINE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE I'LL OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. WELL MISS PATTERSON
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING CHEST
MEASURE FORWARD IT IS FIVE THIS
SORT OF LEGISLATION THAT FRANKLY
I WISH WE DIDN'T NEED TO HAVE
ANOTHER- BUT AS YOU AS YOU KNOW
THIS COMMITTEE HAS CONDUCTED A
NUMBER OF OVERSIGHT HEARINGS ON
THE FISCAL PROJECT I SHARE YOUR
VERY GRAVE. VERY GRAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PROJECT AND I THINK
THAT THE HEIGHTENED OVERSIGHT
MEASURES THAT YOU ARE PROPOSING
IN YOUR BILL OR VERY APPROPRIATE
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES SO HAPPY
TO. SUPPORT THAT THE BILL TODAY
AND I RECOMMEND AND I VOTE I'M-
I SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. PETRIE-NORRIS I. THE GREAT.
BLACKIE ALL RIGHT. MEDINA I
DON'T PURCHASES AND WILSON TO
CALL ME PATTERSON HI THERE AGAIN
. I'M READY TO SIGN. THANK YOU.
AT FIVE OH THAT BELL IS OUT AND
WE BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON. RIGHT
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR
AUTHORS I'D SAY- OFFICE IS
WATCHING THE LIVE STREAM WE ARE
WAITING FOR AUTHORS IN ROOM FOUR
THREE SEVEN ACCOUNTABILITY
MINISTRY TO REVIEW CENTER OFFERS
AUTHORS AT. YES EXCELLENT
SUGGESTION FROM OUR VICE CHAIR
LET'S GO AHEAD AND DISPENSED
WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR I WE
HAVE THREE BILLS ON TODAY'S
CONSENT CALENDAR. AB SIXTEEN
HUNDRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NGUYEN AB EIGHTEEN OH SIX- BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS. I AND AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FONG ON MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
UP THANK YOU I'M TRYING TO MOVE
INTO FAST. DO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND SO MOVED. ALL RIGHT
I THINK WE HAD A MOTION FOR
MISTER PATTERSON SECOND FROM AS
WELL SEND. NOW MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. OKAY
MOTION IT DO PASSED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS SB SIX HUNDRED.
PETRIE-NORRIS I PATTERSON. GREAT
LACKEY HI MEDINA RODRIGUEZ AND
WILSON HI THAT PASSED OKAY GREAT
AS- SIX- THAT BELL IS OUT. AND
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS OUT WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN MORNING I WILL NEED TO
FILE ITEM NOT NUMBER FIVE A. B.
TWENTY ONE THIRTY FIVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN YOU ARE READY THANK
YOU- AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY FIVE
ADOPTS THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE UPDATED
HIGH RISK CYBERSECURITY REPORT
FROM EARLIER THIS YEAR AS THEY
RELATE TO STATE AN S. ENTITIES
THAT DO NOT REPORT TO THE
GOVERNOR. THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
REQUIRE THAT THESE STATE
ENTITIES THAT INCLUDE OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS ADOPTED
PROVISION SECURITY STANDARDS
ASSESS THEMSELVES AGAINST THOSE
STANDARDS AND REPORT BACK TO THE
LEGISLATURE. ON THEIR COMPLIANCE
THIS IS AN ISSUE I'VE BEEN
TRYING TO FIX SINCE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND IT BROUGHT BACK
EVERY YEAR TO ENSURE WE FIX THIS
GLARING GAP IN OUR STATE'S
CYBERSECURITY OVERSIGHT.
EVERYONE IN THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ALMOST EVERYBODY IN THIS CITY
THAT WAS HERE LAST YEAR HAS
SUPPORTED THIS BILL WHEN IT CAME
BEFORE COMMITTEE THESE
CERTIFICATIONS WILL ENABLE US TO
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED OVERSIGHT.
THANK YOU. THE BILL. YEAH THANK
YOU AND AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN
I BELIEVE THERE'S NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT CORRECT
THERE'S NOBODY ALL RIGHT WE'VE
BEEN HEARING THIS FOR YEARS
UNDERSTATE SOMEBODY YES KILLING
IT BUT NOT THIS YEAR NOT THIS
YEAR THIS THIS IS THIS IS YOUR
TIME FIFTY FIVE ARE THERE IS
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT. ANYONE IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SEEN NONE I'LL BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH ABOUT THE MAIENSCHEIN
MEDINA I KNOW I AM NOT ALONE IN
APPRECIATING YOUR LEADERSHIP ON
THIS VERY IMPORTANT AND CRITICAL
ISSUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WOULD
LIKE TO CLOSE THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK ME RIGHT BUT THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION- FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA SECOND
FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
OP SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB TWO ONE THREE FIVE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFERRED
TO APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS
HI. PATTERSON LACKEY HI MEDINA
RODRIGUEZ AND WILSON. THANK YOU
FOR I CLICKED AT SIX ZERO THAT
BELL IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO AHEAD AND ADD
MOVE TO. FILE ITEM THREE I AB IS
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA. WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU VENTURE MEMBERS
A BEGIN BY ACCEPTING. AMENDMENTS
FOR SUGGESTED WE SEE PROVIDED
OFFICE BUT APARTMENT GENERAL
SERVICES. ABI HOPE TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE DEPARTMENT
STAKEHOLDERS TO ENSURE THE BILL
COULD BE IMPLEMENTED IN STATE
DOLLARS HELD ACCOUNTABLE. AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THE
CALIFORNIA DEFORESTATION FREE
PROCUREMENT ACT WOULD REQUIRE
ANY ENTITIES CONTRACT OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO CERTIFY
THEY'RE NOT CONTRIBUTING TO
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION EITHER
DIRECTLY. OR THROUGH THEIR
SUPPLY CHAINS. THE DESTRUCTION
AND DEGRADATION OF TROPICAL
FORESTS DUE TO INDUSTRIAL SCALE
EXPLOITATION ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF GLOBAL
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
CONTRIBUTING TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
ADDITIONALLY THEY HAVE WIDE
RANGING IMPACTS ON BIODIVERSITY
AND HUMAN RIGHTS ESPECIALLY WITH
REGARD TO PROTECTING INDIGENOUS
LED STEWARDSHIP AND GOVERNANCE
OF THESE LANDS. AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE IS MODELED AFTER
THE EXISTING SWEAT FREE CODE OF
CONDUCT BUT SUCH SHOP FREE CODE
OF CONDUCT FOR STATE CONTRACTS
AND PROCUREMENT BAN AGAINST
CHILD LABOR- AS THE FIFTH-LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
CALIFORNIA'S PURCHASING POWER
HAS SIGNIFICANT MARKET FORCE
THIS BILL BUILT WIELDS THAT
FORCED TO EXTEND OUR STATE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP GEN A
TROPICAL FOREST. BY ADOPTING THE
PROCUREMENT POLICY BEING SUE
THAT THE STATE IS NOT AN
INADVERTENT CONTRIBUTED TO THE
DEGRADATION OF TROPICAL FORESTS
AND SIGNAL TO GLOBAL MARKETS THE
DESTRUCTIVE COMMODITY DRIVEN
DEFORESTATION WILL NOT BE
TOLERATED A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE ENJOYS BROAD SUPPORT FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY EXPERTS
WILDLIFE ADVOCATES A COMMERCIAL
BUSINESSES INVESTORS THAT
SUPPORT SUSTAINABLE PRACTICES
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL'S SPONSORS ARE NICK SACK IN
ABOUT HALF OF SUCH COMPASSION
LEGISLATION AND DAVID COMPOUNDED
READING TESTIMONY ON BEHALF. OF
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH. THE FIRST
RIGHT. HI MISTER SECOND UP TO
MIND OR DO YOU WANT TO GO AHEAD
AND I WILL BEGIN WITH- MISTER
CONTAINER GOOD MORNING
CHAIRWOMAN CONGRATULATIONS. GOOD
MORNING YOUR WOMAN DAVID CANTON
I'M DAVID- ON BEHALF OF FRIENDS
OF THE EARTH ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE. EVERY THREE DAYS THE WORLD
LOSES AN AREA OF TROPICAL FOREST
THE SIZE OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES WHAT DOES THE WORLD LOSE
WE LOSE OUR TROPICAL FORESTS WE
LOSE COUNTLESS SPECIES SAMATAR
RHINOS OR NAY AND ARRANGE A
TANG'S GREAT APES AND
INNUMERABLE MIGRATORY BIRDS. WE
LOSE INDIGENOUS PEOPLE CULTURES
LANGUAGES AND LYFT WAYS AND WE
LOSE OUR BAT LAST BEST CHANCE TO
PRESENT AND MITIGATE RUN AWAY
CLIMATE CHAOS. BECAUSE A QUARTER
OF GLOBAL GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS RESULT FROM
DEFORESTATION AND DEGRADATIONOF
INTACT PRIMARY FOREST. IN
GLASGOW LAST YEAR THE US JOINED
OVER ONE HUNDRED COUNTRIES IN A
PLEDGE TO HALT AND REVERSE
GLOBAL DEFORESTATION BY TWENTY
THIRTY. ON EARTH THEY JUST LAST
WEEK PRESIDENT BIDEN ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER TO RE DOUBLE
THAT COMMITMENT. AND
SPECIFICALLY TO TAKE ACTION TO
ADDRESS COMMODITY DRIVEN
DEFORESTATION IN TANDEM WITH
DEVELOPING NATIONS. AT THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN YOU WENT
CLIMATE SUMMIT GOVERNMENTS AND
INDUSTRY CAME TOGETHER. AND
SIGNED AT NEW YORK DECLARATION
ON FOREST THIS IS A COMMITMENT
TO REDUCE GLOBAL DEFORESTATION
BY HALF BY TWENTY TWENTY. AND
ENDED BY TWENTY THIRTY
CALIFORNIA WAS A SIGNATORY TO
THIS DECLARATION. WHEN THE U. N.
ACEST PROGRESS IN TWENTY TWENTY
WHAT DID IT FIND NOT ONLY HAD
THE WORLD MISS THE TWENTY TWENTY
TARGET BUT GLOBAL DEFORESTATION
IT ACTUALLY INCREASED BY OVER
40% DEFORESTATION IS INCREASING
BECAUSE THERE'S NO ECONOMIC A
REGULATORY INCENTIVE TO STOP IT.
THIS MEASURE WILL AND INITIATE A
GROUNDBREAKING APPROACH TO USING
THE POWER OF THE PUBLIC PURSE TO
REVERSE ONE OF THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE OF HUMAN AND
CORPORATE ACTIVITIES. A STUDY BY
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH REVEALS
THAT ROUGHLY ONE QUARTER OF
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC PURCHASING
MAY BE LINKED TO TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION. THAT'S SIX
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
PROCUREMENT THAT COULD BE
LEVERAGED TO SAVE THE WORLD'S
FORESTS. BUT INSTEAD OF PAYING
FOR THEIR DESTRUCTION. TO THE
INDUSTRY OPPOSITION WE SAY THIS
BILL DOES NOT ACTUALLY BANNED
ANYTHING. THIS BILL MERELY
LEGISLATIVE PROCUREMENT
PREFERENCE FOR GOODS THAT DO NO
HARM. BY MAKING THIS PROCUREMENT
PREFERENCE CALIFORNIA SENT A
VERY CLEAR MARKET SIGNAL TO THE
MARKETS. THAT'S WHY EVERY
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION IN
THE COUNTRY WANT TO SEE THIS
BILL BECOME LAW. NOT ONLY THAT
THE INVESTMENT COMMUNITIES
BEHIND THIS BILL LAST YEAR
COALITION OF RESPONSIBLE
INVESTORS. WHO COLLECTIVELY
MANAGE ONE POINT FIVE TRILLION
DOLLARS IN ASSETS SUPPORTED THE
CASE THAT AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE IS GOOD FOR BUSINESS. THANK
YOU AND WE ASK FOR YOUR I. YEAH.
MR SACK HELLO CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
NICHOLAS SOCKET DIRECTOR AT
SOCIAL COMPASSION IN LEGISLATION
PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THE BILL- I
BELIEVE THAT THE AUTHOR
STATEMENT AND THE STATEMENT BY.
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH SAID MOST
OF WHAT NEEDS TO BE SAID I JUST
WANT TO ADD. THE CALIFORNIANS OF
ALL PARTY SUPPORT- THIS ACTION A
TWENTY TWENTY ONE POLL CONDUCTED
BY TOP POLLSTER. DATA ORBITAL
SHOWED THAT 84% OF REGISTERED
VOTERS IN THE STATE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT OUR STATE
PROCUREMENT POLICIES
CONTRIBUTING TO DEFORESTATION.
THIS CONCERN TRANSLATE 281%
SUPPORTING THE POLICY OF THE
BILL. THAT PASSED THIS BILL
SIMPLE. WILL DETERMINE WHETHER
OUR STATE GOVERNMENT BUYS
PRODUCTS FROM COMPANIES THAT ARE
DOING BEST BY OUR MOST IMPORTANT
FOREST INDIGENOUS PEOPLES. AND
ALL OF US WHO WANT A HABITABLE
PLANET. OR WILL OUR STATE TURN A
BLIND EYE. AND CONTINUE BUYING
PRODUCTS PRODUCED BY COMPANIES
DRIVING TROPICAL DEFORESTATION
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR HELP. THANK YOU I AND I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. I CA. WELL GO AHEAD
AND HI HERE FROM ROBERT SPIEGEL
WHO'S JOINING US FROM THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION- AND
AUDREY READ JACK FROM CBI.
MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR GOOD MORNING MEMBERS IT'S-
NICE TO BE BACK HERE AFTER A TWO
YEAR HIATUS IS A COMMITTEE ROOM
THAT I SERVED IN FOR ABOUT A
DECADE PRIOR TO GOING TO THE
PUBLIC SECTOR PRIVATE SECTOR
EXCUSE ME SO IT'S GONNA BACK ROB
SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OFF
ON BEHALF OF A COALITION OF
OTHER BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY
SUPPOSED AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE WE DO UNDERSTAND RECOGNIZE
AND APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS UNFORTUNATELY GIVEN
THE SWEEPING IMPACTS OF THE
LEGISLATION ON INDUSTRY AND
BUSINESS- WE WILL NOT BE
REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION TO THAT
BILL. AND STILL HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS WITH THE LANGUAGE
MOVING FORWARD. THAT STATED OUR
OPPOSITION WHAT OTHER MANY
OUTSTANDING IF MANY OUTSTANDING
ISSUES GIVEN THE BREADTH OF THE
IMPACT OF THIS LEGISLATION A
WHOLE LIST OF INDUSTRIES ARE A
WHOLE HOST OF INDUSTRIES
INCLUDING. THOSE ASSOCIATED
PAPER AND BUILDING PRODUCTS SOLD
ALSO- AUTOMOTIVE. AND FOOD ALL
REALLY DO MY BEST TO KIND OF SUM
UP. SOME OFTHOSE THREE KEY
ISSUES. FIRST THE SCOPE OF AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE OF THE
PRODUCTS THERE AND THE
INDUSTRIES IN THAT IT MEANT
BUSINESSES IMPACTED IS MASSIVE.
THE DEFINITION OF A FORTRESS
COMMODITY IS OVERLY BROAD MAKING
IT SIGNIFICANTLY CHALLENGING FOR
THE STATE TO PROCURE NEEDED
INVENTORY. SECOND AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE IS NOT JUST
LIMITED. TO TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION. THE LEGISLATION
OF DEATH- THE LEGISLATION'S
DEFINITION OF TROPICAL FOREST.
ALSO INCLUDES PEATLANDS AND
PEATLANDS CONTAINS ITS OWN
SEPARATE DEFINITION IN THE
STATUTE- EXCUSE ME IN THE
LEGISLATION. WHICH IS NOT
EXISTING ANY TROPICAL
ENVIRONMENT. OR EXCUSE ME THAT
PEOPLE ENTER SEPARATELY TO FIND
OUT COULD PERMAFROST TUNDRA. FOR
THE COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION WE
HAVE ASKED WHY IS A BILL WITH A
STATED FOCUS ON TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION. ENCOMPASSING
FROZEN LANDS ASSOCIATED WITH
TUNDRA WHICH DO NOT EXIST IN A
TROPICAL ENVIRONMENT. UNTIL THE
RECENT. AMENDMENTS OF AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. IT WAS
IDENTICAL BEFORE ONE SIX THAT
WAS VETOED BY GOVERNOR SOME LAST
YEAR. NOW IN PART OF THE BILL'S
IMPACT IN THE NATION PROVINCES
OF CANADA WE BELIEVE THAT AB
NINETEEN SEVEN DOT SEVENTY NINE
RE INSTITUTE TO RECREATES THE
SAME ISSUES FROM LAST YEAR. AND
THIRDLY WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT- ELIMINATOR
DELETED THE REFERENCES TO THE
FOURTH POLICY THAT WOULD BE
CREATED BY BILL. THE LANGUAGE
STILL HAS ADMINISTRATIVE
DISCRETION TO G. G. S. AS TO
WHICH FORCED ROOF COMMODITIES
WILL ACTUALLY BE COVERED BY THE
DGS DEFORESTATION FREE CODE OF
CONDUCT. NOW AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE HAS THE ABILITY TO CREATE A
DE FACTO BAN ON FOR FIRST
PRODUCTS BECAUSE IT REQUIRES DGS
TO IDENTIFY AND USE AT LEAST
FOUR. FROM PALM OIL SOY BEEF
WHETHER LUMBER. PAPER WOOD
COFFEE AND WOOD PULP THAT WOULD
BE SUBJECT TO THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THAT ABOUT LISTING ABOUT
BILL. NOW GIVEN THAT THE LIST
CAN ONLY BE UPDATED ONCE EVERY
THREE YEARS PRODUCTS LEFT OFF
THAT LIST WOULD OTHERWISE NOT BE
SUITABLE FOR CERTIFIED FOR
PROCUREMENT PURPOSES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. WE
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSIONS WITH
MEANT BY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND STAFF AND WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
ATTENTION WHATEVER WE DO
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR NO VOTE ON
THE BILL. THE MORNING CARE
BETWEEN OR IS THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RGP PAYCHECK FROM
CRUISE STRATEGIES REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. AND ALONG WITH
ROBERT RUN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO AB NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. AM
THE BILL EQUIRES A CONTRACTOR
CONTRACTING WITH THE STATE
AGENCY TO CERTIFY THE WOOD OR
FOREST RISK COMMODITIES NOT BE
SOURCE FROM CERTAIN REGIONS
REGARDLESS OF EXISTING POLICIES
TO PROTECT THOSE AREAS. THIS
RUNS CONTRARY TO THE CURRENT
HIGH STANDARDS FOR NORTH AMERICA
SUSTAINABLE FORESTRY PRACTICES
AND CERTIFICATION STANDARDS THAT
APPLY CHAIN OF CUSTODY
REQUIREMENTS WHICH CREATES
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS FOR
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION.
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF HOME BUILDERS
LUMBER PRICES HAVE ALREADY
SKYROCKETED THREE HUNDRED AND
50% SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC. AND DUE TO COVERT
RELATED DEMANDS SUCH AS AN
INCREASED DEMAND FOR NEW HOMES
AND HOME REPAIR AND WEBER
RENOVATIONS. DIMENSIONAL LUMBER
AND PANEL PRODUCTS ARE ALREADY
AT RECORD HIGH LEVELS MORE THAN
THREE TIMES THE TWENTY YEAR
AVERAGE PRICE WITH THE CURRENT
CHALLENGES TO OBTAIN QUALITY
SUSTAINABLE NUMBER AT A TIME
WHEN WE ARE TRYING TO MEET THE
DEMAND FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AND RESPOND TO THE STATE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE GOALS THIS BILL
IT'S A HUGE BARRIER IN INBOX
COSTA CONSTRUCTIONS FURTHERMORE
CANADA IS THE SECOND LARGEST
EXPORTER OF WOOD TO CALIFORNIA
TOTALING THIRTY THREE PERCENT.
SO BY RESTRICTING PARTS OF
CALIFORNIA'S MARKET RESEARCH FOR
SUSTAINABLY HARVEST FOREST
PRODUCTS ON TOP OF THE CURRENT
U. S. DUTIES ON CANADIAN
SOFTWOOD LUMBER. THE BILL WILL
NEGATIVELY AFFECT THE SUPPLY OF
LUMBER COMING INTO CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS RAISES CONCERNS FOR THE
IMPACT ON OUR EFFORTS TO SECURE
LOW INCOME HOUSING. BRING YOUR
RESIDENCE AND WE KNOW THAT THIS
WILL HAVE IMPACTS BEYOND
PROCUREMENT BY DECREASING
AVAILABILITY FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS AND CREATE FURTHER
CHALLENGES FOR THE HOUSING
MARKET. SO CBA HAS BEEN A STRONG
LEADER IN THE GREEN BUILDING
PROCESSES AND SUPPORT
SUSTAINABLE MANAGED FOREST AND
RENEWABLE FOREST PRODUCTS BUT
EVEN WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS WERE CONCERNED A-
TENANT CONSEQUENCES OF THE BILL.
PLEA WITH TRADING PARTNERS THAT
HAVE SOME OF THE WORLD'S HIGHEST
AND MOST STRINGENT ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS THANK. YOU THANK YOU.
HI IS THERE ANYWAY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
KELLERMAN'S IN ON BEHALF OF
SERIES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR CHRIS MCKAY
LEE ON BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES IN
OPPOSITION AND ALSO MY COLLEAGUE
ROB MUTRIE ASKED ME TO SPEAK
THAT THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IS ALSO ON RECORD IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR MEMBERS LIMIT K. ON BEHALF
OF L. PEOPLE THINK SOLUTIONS IN
OPPOSITION EVEN WITH AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK I'VE BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION FOR. A FEW OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL THE FOREST
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION OF CANADA.
AMERICAN WOOD COUNCIL WESTERN
WOOD PRESERVERS INSTITUTE AND
THE INDIGENOUS RESOURCE NETWORK
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT
I'VE SEEN. NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM- I'LL GO AHEAD AND
OPEN IT UP FOR. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
. MISTER K. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS CALL ON COMEY CURIOUS
AS TO WHY YOU THINK THIS IS THE
RIGHT TIME FOR THIS LEGISLATION
DOESN'T SEEM TO BE A GREAT TIME
TO BE- PUTTING RESTRICTIONS INTO
THE MARKET PLACE GIVEN THE-
CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE SEEING
KIND OF ACROSS THE BOARD ACROSS
THE ECONOMY. I DON'T THINK IT'S
RIGHT TIME AT THE RIGHT TIME WAS
PROBABLY TWENTY YEARS AGO- THERE
THE REALITY IS THAT- WE HAVEN'T
DONE ENOUGH TO PROTECT OUR
TROPICAL FORCE THIS SPECIFICALLY
APPLIES ONLY TO TROPICAL.
FORESTS AND SPECIFICALLY ONLY
APPLIES TO STATE PROCUREMENT I'M
NOT UP BY HOUSING DEVELOPERS AND
WHAT HAVE YOU SO- IT'S THE THAT
WERE ALREADY AS WAS INDICATED
BY. OTHER WITNESSES- THAT THAT
SPOKE BEFORE YOU ARRIVED. WE ARE
pSET IN TERMS OF COMBATING
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION. WELL FOR
BEHIND OUR GOALSAND- AND WE'RE
TWENTY YEARS PAST DUE WISELY
BROADER THAN. WELL I WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE A BROADER REDUCTION
NARROWED IT BASED UPON
OPPOSITION CONCERNS- BUT AND
THAT'S WHY I WAS LITERALLY IN
CANADA IN OCTOBER AND THEY WERE
VERY GRATEFUL- THE MOVE BOREEL
FOREST AND REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION. AND SO- IT'S
ACTUALLY MORE NARROW BECAUSE OF
CONCERNS RAISED BY FROM- PRIVATE
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS OTHER
GOVERNMENTS THEY BY THAT OUR
GRIEF WE'VE NARROWED IT- BECAUSE
OF THE CURRENT CHALLENGES IN
OPPOSITION THAT MAYBE IT'S NOT
THE RIGHT TIME. WELL WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS WE'RE FOCUSING ON THE
TROPICAL FORESTS. AND WE WILL
REMOVE THE BOREAL FORESTS. AND
SO IF YOUR SUGGESTION IS THAT
WHENEVER WE RECEIVE OPPOSITION
THAT IS THE WRONG TIME FOR
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULDN'T GET
ANYTHING. ACCOMPLISHED AT ALL-
THE REALITY IS THAT OF THE LAST
FOR LAST YEAR I SEE BY CBI HIS
PRIMARY ISSUE WAS THE BOREAL
FOREST WE REMOVED THAT THERE'S A
BILL. CONSISTENTLY AND CLEARLY
REFERS TO TROPICAL REGIONS ONLY-
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS THE
PRIMARY REQUEST WAS THIRD PARTY
CERTIFICATION- AND WE ALSO-
ABIDED BY THAT AND SO WE'RE
DOING EVERYTHING. TO MAKE IT AS
CLEAR AS POSSIBLE THAT AND WE'VE
ALSO EMPOWER DGS- OF IT TO COME
UP WITH THE STANDARDS THAT WORK
FOR THEM AND SO IN IN. WORKING
WITH THE GOVERNOR SINCE THE HAVE
OF RETAIL AND SO- LOOK YOU KNOW
WE CAN. PUT OUR HEAD IN THE SAND
CONTINUE TO IGNORE. AN ISSUE
THAT'S IMPACTING ALL OF US
AROUND THE GLOBE OR OR NOT- THE
REALITY IS THAT AGAIN THIS IS
JUST STATE PROCUREMENT- PRIVATE
COMPANIES DO NOT HAVE TO.
CONTRACT WITH THE STATED THEY
DON'T USED TO AND THE ONES THAT
DO. ARE ONES THAT- YOU KNOW
SHOULD BE ABLE TO BUY BUT NOT A
SHIPPING COMPANY FORESTATION.
THANK YOU. AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR IF
HE'S DONE ANYTHING TO- TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF SMALL
BUSINESSES. WELL THERE IS THE
REALITY IS THAT BY HAVING A
THIRD PARTY CERTIFICATION THAT
IS ACCESSIBLE- TO ALL IT
ACTUALLY AND I WAS ACTUALLY.
ALSO BE RECORDED YES ON A MOVE
THAT APPLIED TO CONCERNS THAT
THEY HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT
SMALLER CONTRACTORS AND THE
ABILITY TO ALSO. THE REQUEST OR
OR APPLY FOR PROCUREMENT AND SO
WE'VE DONE EVERYTHING THAT HAS
BEEN ASKED OF US- WORKING WITH
DGS TO MAKE SURE THIS IS AS
ACCESSIBLE. AND EASY A PROGRAM
TO COMPLY WITH AS POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
SECOND QUESTION A SHORT THANKS
FOR BRINGING THIS AFFORD AGAIN
TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUES- JUST A
LITTLE CONCERNED FROM WHAT THE
OPPOSITION TO TALK MORE WITH
REGARD TO INCREASE THE COST OF
MAYBE FUTURE DEVELOPMENTS I'M
NOT SURE IF THERE'S ANYTHING
WORKING CLARIFY ON THAT ARE FOR
START TO LIMIT OUR PRODUCTS
COMING TO- THE STATE TO BE
DEVELOPED AND I KNOW YOU HAD
PREVIOUS LEGISLATION BEFORE THE
MEET THE GOVERNOR VETOED ITS I'M
NOT REALLY SURE IF I CAN GET
THROUGH THIS TIME BUT- BECAUSE
OF THAT I MAY LOOK TO LAY OFTEN
FORGETS AUGUST OF FOUR HOPEFULLY
CAN WITH OPPOSITION. WHAT WE
EXPECT TO SUPPORT ONE SURE THAT
. IT I COULD MADAM CHAIR. WE OF
WORK. WITH THE OPPOSITION MOVED
THE GOAL LINE BECAUSE WE HAVE
ACTUALLY. DONE WHAT. THE
GREATEST OBJECTIONS OF%
OPPOSITION OF THE ADDRESS AND
NOW. THEY'RE FINDING NEW
OBJECTIONS THE REALITIES IS NOT
APPLY. TO PRIVATE. AND
COMMERCIAL DEVELOPMENT. THIS IS
STATE PROCUREMENT. SIMPLY STATE
PROCUREMENT AND SO. IT DOESN'T
APPLY TO HOMEBUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BOB AND WHAT HAVE YOU
IT'S THE STATE PROCUREMENT. OF
COMMODITIES. AND SO I WOULD
REALLY URGE YOU TO CONSIDER. I'M
NOT LAYING OFF BUT- BASED UPON-
ARGUMENTS THAT DO NOT ACTUALLY
ADDRESS WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH
THIS BILL. OF THESE ARGUMENTS
ARE THERE ARE BEING USED
INSTEAD. AS AS TO KIND OF SCARE
US. TO NOT. GO IN THERE THE
DIRECTION. TOWARDS SIMPLY-
ENSURING THAT WE AT THE STATE OR. NOT CONSERVING A TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION. I SAID BOY FOREST
BEEN TO NOT AND THE COMMITTEE
FORCES ALL DOESN'T OUR OWN
FORCE- IT'S- ENSURING. THAT
WE'RE NOT CONTRIBUTING TO
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION AND THAT
MEANS TROPICAL TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION THAT'S NOT PART OF
THE SUSTAINABLE MANAGEMENT
PROGRAM SO IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU
CANNOT GET. ITEMS FROM TROPICAL
REGIONS THAT JUST MEANS THAT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
BEING SUSTAINABLY BECAME. SO I
DO HAVE A COUPLE OF QUSTIONS AB
AND- ALSO YOUR START BY SAYING.
THAT THE I LIKE YOU RECOGNIZE
THE DEFORESTATION IS A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO OUR OUR CLIMATE
CRISIS. I'M CERTAINLY SHARE.
YOUR GOAL. I AROUND ENSURING
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
NOT CONTRIBUTING TO
DEFORESTATION. WHICH IS WHY.
THIS BILL IS ADVANCE OUT ADITUS
COMMITTEE ON A COUPLE OF
OCCASIONS. ON HOWEVER. IT IT'S
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING OUT THERE
SIR ANY OTHER TOPIC IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
CONNECT THE DOTS BETWEEN. YOU
KNOW AND A LOT OF ONE GOAL AND A
- PRACTICAL. IMPLEMENTABLE
POLICY TO ACHIEVE THAT GOAL I'M-
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND FIVE I
GUESS DGS HAD OFFERED A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS TRYING. WITH THE
GOAL OF A TRYING TO BETTER
TARGET THE LEGISLATION. I'M I
HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT
YOU CAN SIT. CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SWEEPING
IMPACTS AND- THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. I GUESS IT. I IF
YOU COULD ADDRESS I'M MISTER
KALRA COUPLE OF THE POINTS THAT
WERE RAISED. IT YOU SAID THAT
IT'S FOCUSED ON. TROPICAL
FORESTS MMHM FIVE. AT THE
OPPOSITION MADE A POINT THAT IT
INCLUDES TUNDRA CAN YOU ADDRESS
THAT IT DOESN'T THAT THE IT
DIDN'T THE BILL HAS NARROWED TO
TROPICAL FOREST ONLY BE REASON
WHY THERE'S REFERENCE THE TUNDRA
IS THAT THAT'S THE GENERAL
ACCEPTED DEFINITION OF PETE
WHICH INCLUDES A WIDE RANGE OF
POTENTIAL- OF BOOK THE
GEOGRAPHIES BUT THE BILL ITSELF
NARROWS IT SIMPLY A TROPICAL IT
IS THE SAME- THIS IS THE SAME
LANGUAGE THAT HAS BEEN THAT WAS
IN THE BILL- THREE AND FOUR
YEARS AGO BEFORE PAUL YEAH WAS
INCLUDED- AND THERE WAS NO
OBJECTION TO IT BECAUSE EVERYONE
UNDERSTOOD. THAT DESPITE HAVING
THAT DEFINITION THAT MAY HAVE
INCLUDED THE WORDS UNDER THE
BILL ITSELF IS STRICTLY
RESTRICTED TO TROPICAL THAT'S
WHY THE GOVERNMENT OF CANADA A
AND- PROBABLY THE END NUMEROUS
PROVINCES OF REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION IS BECAUSE BEING
REMOVED- BORIO- DEEP- AND SO THE
POINT OF ORIGIN DEFINITIONS ARE
LIMITED TO TROPICAL LATITUDES
AND LONGITUDES VERY CLEARLY.
SPELLED OUT IN THE LEGISLATION.
THE YEAH MEDICARE FROM A AT A-
YOU KNOW I QUESTION RESIDES IS
WHY STILL BEEN OF TWO HUNDRED
DECIDED TO BE LISTED IN THE AND
THE- DEFINITIONS OF THIS BILL.
PEATLAND IF THE FIGHT IS
PERMAFROST TUNDRA PERMAFROST
HUNDRED DOES NOT EXIST IN THE
TROPICAL LATITUDES PERIOD IT IS
SOLELY CONFINED IN THE NORTHERN
HEMISPHERE. SIBERIA CANADA
ALASKA GREENLAND. AND THAT
DEFINITION CREATES ITSELF
AMBIGUITY AS TO WHAT THE SCOPE
AND WHAT THE INTENT AND FURTHER
IMPACT OF THIS BILL IS. IT AT IF
OUR WITNESS CAN YELL I'D-
CLARIFYING POINT YEP NOPE
PEATLAND IS ABSOLUTELY FOUND IN
TROPICAL REGIONS PEATLANDS ARE.
HAVE BURNED THERE OUGHT IF YOU.
PAID ATTENTION TO THE FIRES IN
INDONESIA. A TWO OR THREE YEARS
AGO ALL OF THOSE FIRES WERE
PEATLANDS BERNIE. TO PEATLAND IS
DEFINITELY FOUND IN TROPICAL
REGIONS. AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO POINT OUT THAT. IN THE
DEFINITION OF THE OF THE BILL-
IT DOES SAY- A THAT. A FORCE
RISK COMMODITY MEANS A COMMODITY
WHETHER IN RAW OR PROCESSED FORM
THAT IS COMMONLY GROWN DERIVE
POWER SEAT REARED OR PRODUCED ON
LAND WHERE TROPICAL
DEFORESTATION OCCURRED. AS THE
AUTHOR SAID WE ARE COOK CLEARLY
TARGETING TROPICAL REGIONS I
THE BILL. UNDERSTOOD AND IF I
CAN AND DOES THAT COME BACK- TO
THE AUTHOR IS SO UNDERSTANDING
YOUR GOAL IS TO FOCUS ON
TROPICAL DEFORESTATION. AND AM I
CORRECT IN UNDERSTANDING THAT IF
THERE IS LANGUAGE OR FIVE
PHRASING IN THE BILL THAT. MAKES
THE THAT IS IT CONTRARY TO THAT
STATED INTENT YOU ARE FIVE OPEN
TO WORKING WITH OPPOSITION TO
ENSURE THAT NOT JUST IN GOAL BUT
IN PRACTICE THE BILL FOCUSES
HEAVILY ON TROPICAL. UNIVERSE
STATION THAT MEASURE ABSOLUTELY
EVERYTHING WE WANT TO STRIKE OUT
THE WORD PERMAFROST AND MAKES IT
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE DO THAT
WERE MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THEM TO DO THAT I'M JUST
PUTTING THE- CAPTIVE DEFINITION
BROAD DEFINITIONAL WHAT PETE IS
EVEN THOUGH THE BILL FOR
SQUARELY FOCUSES ON TROPICAL BUT
IT MAKES THEM FEEL BETTER TO DO
THAT. HAPPY TO DO THAT BECAUSE
OF HOW TO MAKE IT AS CLEAR AS
POSSIBLE THAT WE NOT ONLY REMOVE
OR L. BUT WE HAVE NO INTENTION
OF- OF UP. IN ANY WAY IMPACTING
OR HER HAVING ANY REGULATION ON
ANYTHING OUTSIDE OF THE TROPICAL
OF THE TROPICAL REGIONS OF OUR
OF OUR WORLD. AT ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SAY NINE. I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. UP I
WANT TO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND YOUR COMMITTEE- FOR WORKING
WITH US OF THE LAST COUPLE YEARS
ON THIS- YOU KNOW WITH THE AS I
MENTIONED THE BILL HAS BEEN
NARROWED TO DEAL. WITH OF THE
PRIMARY CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS INCLUDING FROM THE
GOVERNMENT OF CANADA MY- HOME
COUNTRY ROSE BORN- AND- YOU. IT
ONLY IMPACTS. STATE PROCUREMENT
TO MAKE THAT VERY VERY CLEAR-
AND IT'S A BILL THAT HAS
PREVIOUSLY- OBVIOUSLY. MADE IT
TO THIS COMMITTEE BEFORE AND
WE'RE WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND DGS.
TO MAKE SURE THEIR BEST PRACTICE
IN PLACE TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
BUSINESSES. AS EASY AS POSSIBLE
FOR THE PER BUSINESSES TO
COMPLY- AND WE JUST ALSO JUST
GOT THE ADVANCE RECENTLY FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE SOME OF THE
FORTITUDE TO WORK WITH THEM ON
IT. AS WELL AS KEEPING OF YOU IN
YOUR COMMITTEE IN IN THE LOOP ON
ANY. FUTURE CHANGES. FAST
RELIABLE. THANK YOU. AT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WE NEED A MOTION AND THIS. THANK
YOU. IS THERE MOTION.
I'M. THIS WOULD BE A FIRST FOR
ME AS AN HR- PERHAPS.
OKAY AT THAT MEASURE FAILED
BECAUSE I'VE WE WERE UNABLE TO
MOVE THE BALL.
ALL RIGHTS I. LET'S SEE WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM SEVEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER A.
B. TWO FOUR SEVEN AT TWO FOUR
FIVE FOUR- THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS I
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
FOUR- WHICH ENSURES A MORE
TRANSPARENT PUBLIC WORKS
CONTRACTING PROCESS JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES COMPRISED
OF REPRESENTATIVES OF LABOR AND
MANAGEMENT A SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES
TYPICALLY THESE COMPANIES THESE
COMMITTEES COLLABORATE OR
VARIETY OF TOPICS RELATED TO
LABOR COMPLIANCE EMPLOYEE PAY
PLACING THEM IN A UNIQUE
POSITION TO DETECT UNFAIR BEDS
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
MECHANISM TO FILE BID PROTESTS
IN CALIFORNIA LIMITS THE ABILITY
FOR THESE LABOR COMPLIANCE
ENTITIES TO WEIGH IN WITH A
DENTAL FIGHT ISSUES WITH THE
AWARDING OF A CONTRACT. UNDER
COURT CURRENT LAW ONLY A BITTER
WHO IS NOT AWARDED A PUBLIC
WORKS CONTRACT IS ELIGIBLE TO
SUBMIT A PROTEST ADDITIONALLY
CONTRACTORS WHO MAY HAVE
LEGITIMATE REASONS TO PROTEST A
BIT OFTEN FAIL TO DO SO OUT OF
FEAR OF RETRIBUTION A REJECTION
OF FUTURE BIDS FROM THE AWARDING
AGENCY OR OUT OF FEAR OF
UPSETTING CONTRACTORS WHO PAID
TO. THE EFFORT TO ENSURE TROY
PROCESS AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
FOUR AUTHORIZES JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE TO PRODUCE
PROTEST H. ST PUBLIC WORKS
CONTACT TO PROTECT THE STATE
WORK STATE PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACT
IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY
BELIEVE IT WAS NOT AWARDED TO
THE LOWEST BIDDER. HERE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IT'S
TEMPERAMENTS REPRESENTING THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS. THANK YOU- I MAY CUT
MY FORMAL COMMENT SHORT OF AND
MAYBE A MAKE A COUPLE POINTS UP
FIRST OF ALL THIS BILL DOES NOT
EXPAND OR CHANGE YOUR CRITERIA
WHEN YOU COULD FILE A BID
PROTEST IT DOES NOT CHANGE AT
ALL. IT ONLY APPLIES TO STATE
CONTRACTS NOT LOCAL NOT SPECIAL
DISTRICT NOT COUNTY- CITY- IN IN
THE DOES THAT WOULD APPLY TO AN
pIT CONTRACTOR VENDOR TYPE
CONTRACT THIS IS TRADITIONAL
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS. UP FOR
STATE DEPARTMENTS OF. IN A TO
REMIND YOU WHAT ARE LABOR
COMPLAINTS ENTITIES DO THEY THEY
ADMINISTER ART OUR PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS ARETRUST FUND PROGRAMS
OR HEALTH AND WELFARE PROGRAMS.
IN THEY MONITOR COMPLAINTS ON
PUBLIC WORKS PROJECTS WHERE
PAYMENTS ARE REQUIRED FOR
COMPLIANCE IS REQUIRED AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY DO AND- THE
THEORY HIS IF THEY WOULD. HELP
THE WORD AGENCY FOR- MAKE A MORE
INFORMED DECISION TO AVOID
ROAD- AND I'VE ALSO REMIND THE
MEDIA IT'S IN YOUR ANALYSIS THAT
THESE. THESE PROTESTS IN THE
RATIONALE FOR THESE PROTESTS
MUST BE WITHIN TEN DAYS. AFTER
THE PROTESTERS FILED IN THE BID
PROTEST MUST BE FILED PRIOR TO
THE AWARD OF THE CONTRACT- END
UP PLEASE US SUPPLIED ASK YOUR
SUPPORT AND I WOULD MENTION ALSO
THE- STATE COUNCIL CARPENTERS
ARE IN SUPPORT OF. ALSO BUT.
THEY'RE BUSY TODAY. I DON'T
BELIEVE THERE'S A PRICE WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION- IS THERE A- THERE
WE GO YES THERE IS. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SCOTT
GOVERNOR OF HALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS ARE THE
LARGEST UNION SIGNATORY BUILDING
CONTRACTORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO PERFORM IN EXCESS
OF THIRTY BILLION IN
CONSTRUCTIVE ON HIM ANYWAY-
RESPECTFULLY THERE IS A PROCESS
IN PLACE WHEN PROTESTS OCCURRED
TODAY MY MEMBERS WILL WORK WITH
THE CARPENTERS AND LABORS. TO
FILE LEGITIMATE PROTESTS WE'VE
DONE THAT FOR YEARS IT WORKS
FINE- WHY THE OPERATORS DON'T DO
IT I'M NOT SURE BUT AGAIN THAT
IS A PROCESS THAT WORKS TODAY.
THERE IS A BIG DEBATEDOWNSTAIRS
ABOUT IMPEDIMENTS TO HOUSING
THIS IS GOING TO MAKE THAT LOOK
LIKE A WALK IN THE PARK. UNDER
THIS BILL. THE PAINTERS IF
THERE'S NOT A UNION PAINTER
ATTACHED TO THE WINNING BID
LET'S PROTEST AT. THAT EVERYONE
ELSE IN THAT JOB IS OUT OF WORK
SAME THING JURISDICTIONAL
DISPUTES LABOUR'S VERSUS
PLUMBERS LABOUR'S VERSUS-
CARPENTERS LABORS VERSUS
LANDSCAPERS. SHEETMETAL VERSES
THAT ROOFERS EVERY TIME
SOMEONE'S NOT SELECTED PROTEST.
THOSE BIDS ARE ONLY GOOD FOR
THIRTY DAYS SO EVEN IF THE
PROTEST ITSELF HAS NO MERIT
WHATSOEVER. EVERYTHING IS ON
HOLD AND EVERY OTHER CRAFT IS
OUT OF WORK. THIS SIMPLY IS NOT
A GOOD IDEA- IT WILL STALL STATE
PROJECTS FOR JURISDICTIONAL
DISPUTES AGAIN UNION VERSUS NON
UNION AND MY MEMBERS ARE UNION-
THERE IS A PROCESS IN PLACE THAT
HAS WORKED. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
THAT YOU VOTE NO ON THIS MEASURE
. THANK YOU I. THANK YOU OPENING
IT UP FOR TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM
AT ANY AT WITNESSES WISHING TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LIKE MONEGAN IN THE
STATE OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION
. C. NINE ELEVEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I HAVE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR AND CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO BUT I
DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED BY OPPOSITION
AND I THINK THERE ARE- OTHER
EXAMPLES. WHERE AT. WE HAVE SEEN
AGAIN WELL INTENDED POLICIES AND
IF UTILIZED AT. SHIP TO THEN I
STYMIE PROJECTS AGAIN SEE WHAT
SEE WHAT LAWSUITS HAVE KIND OF
BECOME A WAIT A- THERE ANSWERED
IT AND BEEN USED FOR BLACKMAIL
HAVE BEEN USED FOR TO HIJACK
PROJECTS HAVE. AT BEEN. DEPLOYED
BEYOND THE INTENT OF THOSE LAWS
SO IF YOU COULD JUST. AND STERN
AND I GUESS SPEAK TO ANY
OPPORTUNITIES THAT YOU CAN SEATS
YOU SORT OF TIGHTENED THE SCOPE
OF IT TO ENSURE THAT YOU CAN
ACCOMPLISH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO WITHOUT HAVING THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES LEADING
TO. FURTHER PROJECT DELAYS AND-
FOR THIRTIES FUNCTION. AND THE
SO FIRST OF ALL WE'VE WE- AS A
AUTHOR AND IN ESSENCE THE
SPONSORS WE'VE OFFERED
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE OPPOSITION
TO GIVE US SOME AMENDMENTS WERE.
NOT ONLY OPEN TO IT WE I THINK
WE NEED. TO MAKE SURE THERE'S NO
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF TO
DATE WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED IT. I
IF IT GETS OUT HIS COMMITTEE WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BE OPEN- AND
HONEST AND FORTHRIGHT TO MAKE
SURE. ALL THOSE OF CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED- DON'T BECOME A
PROBLEM- I WORK FOR THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES FOR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS. I'VE SEEN HOW IT WORKS
I'VE ALSO SEEN HOWCONTRACTORS.
HAVE DONE SOME THINGS THAT WORK.
ABOVEBOARD AN NFL BUT NOT HELP
TO SMALL BUSINESSES OR SMALL
CONTRACTORS OR EVEN OF PEOPLE
WHO WERE TRYING TO GET A LIVING
WAGE ARE WORKING WAGE. AND THEY
HAD A PLACE TO GO AND THAT WAS
SAID THE BOARD OF PUBLIC WORKS
THEY HAD A PLACE TO GO AND TO
EDUCATE THAT. WE NEVER HAD IN
THE TWENTY FIVE YEARS I WORK FOR
THE CITY BEFORE I RETIRED WE
NEVER HAD ANY DELAYS IN PROJECTS
AND- I WAS DIRECTOR REAL ESTATE.
AND I MADE SURE THAT NONE OF MY
PROJECTS WERE DELAYED AND SO UP
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER HELPFUL
TOOL TO ENSURE THAT DESPAIR
NISSEN IN THE CONTRACTING-
AGAIN- WE ARE WIDE OPEN. TO ANY
AMENDMENTS. THAT THE D.
OPPOSITION MAY HAVE- WE'RE NOT
CLOSE TO IT. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU FOR THAT AT AND- BOB I
THINK YOU KNOW WITH WITH THAT
SPIRIT I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY INTENTIONALLY URGE
YOU TO CONTINUE. IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND- DETERMINE HOW
DO WE THREAD HOW DO WE THREAD
THAT NEEDLE EFFECTIVELY- WITH
THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO PLACE A
RESPECTED AS RELIABLE RIGHT.
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY IF
YOU CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
TWO FOUR FIVE FOUR MOTION IS TO
PASS. AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS HI.
PATTERSON. GREAT I. LACKING NO.
MEDINA HI RODRIGUEZ. AND WILSON
. THE BILL IS. FIVE ALL RIGHT
WONDERFUL AT THAT BILL IS OUT
AND- WE'LL GO AHEAD AND MOVE ON
TO OUR NEXT ITEM THANK YOU
SACRAMENTO- COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT MOVING TO FILE NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWO EIGHT NINE THREE.
THE BILL DALEY. JOB AT. IT IS
NOT DEFINITELY. AT. MISTER JONES
JUST SAID DON'T MESS IT UP. I
LISTEN TO BE VERY ADAM- THIS
BILL PERTHE TO NEEDED FOR THE
STATE THE PUBLIC AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO DETERMINE THE
MOST COST COST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT STATE REGULATIONS.
THIS UPDATES THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURES ACT STANDARDIZED
REGULATORY IMPACT ANALYSIS
PROCESS THAT'S A MOUTHFUL AND
ENSURES THAT STATE AGENCIES
UPDATE THEIR ANALYSES TO REFLECT
COMMENTS PROVIDED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS MORE A TOP
WITH THE ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS
COUNCIL AND MISTER BRAD WILLIAMS
WITH CAPITAL MATRIX CONSULTING
FOR BACKGROUND ON THE
STANDARDIZED REGULATORY IMPACT
ANALYSIS PROCESS. TAKE CARE I
WON'T EVEN ATTEMPT TO SAY THAT.
IF THEY HAVE NO I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'D WEAR
A TOP HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BUSINESS COUNCIL
HAPPY TO BE HERE AS A SPONSOR OF
THE MEASURE AND- NOT A WHOLE LOT
TO ADD OTHER THAN- YOU KNOW AS
YOU WELL KNOW BY WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE CONSIDERS A
STATUTORY CHANGE YOU GO THROUGH
A ROBUST- TRANSPARENT PROCESS-
IN ORDER TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES.
BUT OFTENTIMES ON THE LAWMAKING
DOESN'T END WITH A SIGNATURE ON
THE ON THAT BILL AND ADDITIONAL
RULE MAKING IN LAWMAKING OCCURS
BY THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH I'M
THROUGH THE REGULATORY PROCESS
AND JUST AS YOU EXPECT A FISCAL
REVIEW OF YOUR- LEGISLATION
THROUGH THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES THIS BILL IS INTENDED
TO PROVIDE THAT FISCAL REVIEW
WITHIN THE REGULATORY PROCESS.
AND SO WE THINK IT'S A COMMON
SENSE BILL- TO IMPROVE THE TORY
PROCESS THAT- THAT'S ONGOING
THREE DAY IN CALIFORNIA AND WITH
THAT WE WOULD ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. MISTER HI THANK
YOU MATTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'M
GOING TO CALL THE STANDARD
REGULATORY IMPACT ASSESSMENT
SERENA IF YOU DON'T MIND JUST TO
- SO- I WORK WITH CAPTAIN MITCH
WAS CONSULTING I'VE- WORKED ON-
ANALYZING MANY DIFFERENT
SERENA'S ANOTHER REGULATORY
ACTIONS AND- I BELIEVE THAT AB
TWENTY EIGHT NINETY THREE IS A
GOOD GOVERNMENT BILL THAT
SUBSTANTIALLY IMPROVES
CALIFORNIA'S RULE MAKING
PROCESS- YOU KNOW IF YOU KNOW
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES
ACT SETS FORTH A VERY DETAILED
PROCESS. RULE MAKING AND THERE
ARE MAJOR ROLES FOR ECONOMIC
ANALYSIS ECONOMIC IMPACT
ANALYSIS- AND MEANINGFUL PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AND THE OBJECTIVE
OF THIS IS THAT THE RULE MAKING
THE- REGULATION THAT IS ADOPTED.
BE THE MOST EFFECTIVE- VERY MUCH
CALL I THOUGHT I HAD A SURE OFF
- I BELIEVE EFFECTIVE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE OF ANY ALTERNATIVE-
REGULATORY PROCEDURE. AND SO THE
ACCESS FOR THE AMBITIOUS
OBJECTIVES BUT THERE ARE SOME
PROBLEMS WITH HOW IT HIS WORK IN
PRACTICE AND I THINK PERHAPS THE
BIGGEST PROBLEM. IS THAT THE US
REYES- COMPLETED PRIOR TO WIN
THE RULE THE DRAFT RULE IS
INTRODUCED AND OFTEN FAILS TO
LOOK T ROBUST RANGES OF
ALTERNATIVE WAYS OF ACHIEVING
THE SAME OBJECTIVES. SO THE
WHOLE PROCESS OF SORT OF FRONT
LOADED AND- THE FOCUS IS NARROW
BEFORE THE PUBLIC COMBAT PERIOD
BEGINS. AND SO IMPORTANTLY
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT IN
CURRENT LAW THAT THE SU RIAS BE
UPDATED IF A PROPOSAL IS REVISED
AND SO WHAT THAT TENDS TO DO IS
IT LEAVES THE PUBLIC AND THE
AGENCIES SORT OF IN THE DARK
ABOUT. YOU KNOW WHAT SUB AND
REVISIONS TO A REGULATORY A
PROPOSAL- WILL WILL HELP- THIS
BILL ADDRESSES- THIS SHORTCOMING
BY REQUIRING DOUBT THIS REDUCE
BE UPDATED WHEN DRAFT
REGULATIONS ARE MEANINGFULLY
REVISED. AND IT GIVES A PUBLIC
THIRTY DAYS INSTEAD OF THE
CURRENT FIFTEEN DAYS TO HAVE
IT'S A CHANCE TO DIGEST AND
COMMENT ON SUBSEQUENT REVISIONS
THERE ARE OTHER COMPANION
PROVISIONS ARE ALSO VERY
IMPORTANT. INCLUDING- OUR- THE
OUT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
REVIEW THE SERIE A EACH TIME IT
IS UPDATED AND OUT THE AGENCY
INCORPORATE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE RECOMMENDATIONS OR
COMMENTS. IN ITS FINAL DRAFT
ANALYSIS- THERE'S ALSO A
PROVISION THAT REQUIRES ABOUT
THE- THE- RESULTS OF THIS REVIEW
SUMMARIZES IN SORT OF A COMPACT
FASHION. SO YOU KNOW I THINK
BASICALLY JUST CLOSE OF THAT
THESE ARE KEY. ELEMENTS THAT
WILL SUBSTANTIALLY IMPROVE
PROCESS THAT IS ALREADY PRETTY
ROBUST BUT IT CAN DEFINITELY GET
BETTER HI AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT. I THEIR NOTE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WILL GO
AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP FOR
TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM ANYONE
WISHING TO TEST TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT. HELLO MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FIVE INTERVENE ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS REX
W. HEIM ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. ROB
SPIEGEL CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION OF ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING ARE NOT DEALING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
. C. NINE WILL OPEN IT UP FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. C. NINE I'LL
JUST SAY I CERTAINLY AGREE THIS
IS A COMMON SENSE MEASURE THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE A CLOSER BRIEFLY IN OF
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND POINT OUT THAT MR
WILLIAMS WORKED FOR YEARS FOR
THE L. A. L. AND- THAT'S WHY HE
HE'S HE'S GOOD AT GETTING INTO
THE WEEDS- ARE. AND THIS IS
PARTIALLY A RESULT OF AN LA A
RECOMMENDATION FROM FIVE YEARS
AGO SO YEAH I UNDERTOOK THANK
YOU I WOULD YOU HAVE A MOTION HI
MISTER GRAY SECOND FOR MR
RODRIGUEZ. ODD SECRETARY IF YOU
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS PETRIE-NORRIS. HI
PATTERSON HI. GREAT HI. LACKING
FIVE MEDINA HI RODRIGUEZ. FIVE
WILSON FIVE. ALL RIGHT AT SEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL THANK YOU
MEDICARE AND THANKS TO ALL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU. ALRIGHT
WE ARE WAITING FOR ONE AUTHOR-
MAYES QUIRK-SILVA TO JOIN US
WHILE WE ARE WAITING IF WE CAN
PLEASE LET'S GO OUT AND CALL.
THE ROLL SET ABSENT MEMBERS CAN
ADD ON TO PREVIOUS SPELLS. WE'LL
BEGIN WITH BILLS ON CONSENT AB
SIXTEEN HUNDRED AB EIGHTEEN OH
SIX AND AB NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE
ARE DO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS. AND BELIEVE IT
IS AT GREAT A. B. SIXTEEN
HUNDRED. I AB EIGHTEEN OH SIX I
. AB NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE. THE
GREAT YEAR. OKAY M. I BELIEVE WE
HAVE EIGHTEEN. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY NINE HUNDRED ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAEME- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ. TO LEAVE THAT
CONCLUDES THAT.
AT I HAVE A AB TWENTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE ON CALL THAT IS A MEMBER-
WINS BILL A. B. TWENTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
GREAT. I THAT'S ALL OF THEM.
SHE MADE THE MOTION PICTURE
DOLLARS COULD UPSET ACTION YEAH
YOU CAN MAKE FUTURE. WHICH CAN
YOU SECOND. QUESTIONS SO. THE
SCHOOL HELLO. FIRST OF ABOUT.
FULL WE THEY WERE TO. I THINK A
LOT OF RAIN.
GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA I HAVE A RIGHT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE. MEMBERS ORDER.
THE BILL ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM SIX AB.
TWENTY TWO THIRTY THREE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHEN YOU'RE READY. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND I AM
HERE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY THREE- A STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES BILL. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY THREE SIX TO CODIFY AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND IMPLEMENT
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS ON STATE SURPLUS
PROPERTIES IN ORDER TO ADD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHICH ARE
STATE IS DESPERATELY LACKING.
AND TWENTY NINETEEN GOVERNOR
NEWSOM ISSUED AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
N. ZERO SIX NINETEEN IN WHICH HE
ORDERED THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT IN THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY TO
IDENTIFY AND PRIORITIZE STATE
SURPLUS PROPERTIES FOR COST
EFFECTIVE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS.
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE IT THERE WERE
FORTY FOUR THOUSAND PARCELS THAT
WERE IDENTIFIED BUT ONLY A FEW
OF THESE PROPERTIES I HAVE BEEN
DEEMED SUITABLE FOR HOUSING. IN
ADDITION TO THAT IF YOU CAN
BELIEVE IT OUT OF FORTY FOUR
THOUSAND PARCELS THERE ARE ONLY
NINETEEN THAT NOW HOW
PERSPECTIVE HOUSING PLAN NONE OF
THOSE PROPERTIES OUT OF FORTY
FOUR THOUSAND. EVEN THOUGH
NINETEEN HAVE SOME PLANS NONE OF
THOSE PROPERTIES HAVE UNITS THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY BEEN BUILT. THE
STATE'S NEED FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS SIGNIFICANT AS WE
KNOW I'M JUST LEAVING HOUSING
COMMITTEE WHERE WE NEED- FOR
WELL OVER A MILLION NEW UNITS
ACCORDING TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE A
REPORT ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING. PARTNERSHIP ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA HOUSEHOLDS LACKED
ACCESS AFFORDABLE HOUSING. JUST
TO JUMP OFF REAL QUICKLY I HAVE
A TWENTY NINE YEAR OLD SON WHO.
IS IN THE RENTAL MARKET AND JUST
CALLED ME THIS MORNING TO GET
ADVICE ABOUT NOW A TWO BEDROOM
THAT IS THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED AND
ORANGE COUNTY WHICH THAT UNIT
WOULD HAVE BEEN. TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED A YEAR AGO AND HE IS
COMPETING WITH MANY OTHERS- FOR
A ONE TWO BEDROOM UNIT FOR
THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED. SO THIS
MEANS WE NEED TO BUILD WHERE WE
CAN WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITH
ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IS MARK STIVERS WITH
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP AND- AND I BELIEVE
WE'RE ONLY GOING TO HAVE MORE
TODAY RIGHT. THANK YOU GREAT
THANK YOU MARK STIVERS THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
AT THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER ON ACCESS SITES INARGUES
BEEN A RESOUNDING SUCCESS AT
TODAY THE STATE HAS OFFERED
NINETEEN PROPERTIES. ALREADY
IDENTIFIED SHOTS SITES PER SHOW
THE PROGRAM'S POTENTIAL TO
CREATE THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL HOMES TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S UNPRECEDENTED
HOUSING CRISIS. AND MAKING THIS
PROGRAM PERMANENT BY CODIFIED IN
STATUTEIN INSTITUTIONALIZING
THE STATE'S PROCEDURES WILL ONLY
MAGNIFY THE PROGRAM'S IMPACT. AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY THREE ENSURES
THAT THAT'S IMPORTANT PROGRAM
WILL EXTEND BEYOND OUR CURRENT
GOVERNOR. AND FURTHER PROJECT
PERIODIC REVIEWS WILL INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF SITES AND HOMES
THAT CAN BE BUILT. MEETING KELAS
OF CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE
HOUSING NEEDS DEMANDS A LONG
TERM COMMITMENT CONTINUALLY
REASSESSING IN OFFERING STATE
ACCESS SITE PROPERTIES FOR THE
PURPOSE IS AN INTERVAL INTERVAL
PART OF THAT EFFORT AND WE
REALLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS MEASURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I AND THERE ARE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP FOR
TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
C. NINE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. C. NINE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHT CNN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD JUST APPRECIATE AN
AYE VOTE RESPECTFULLY THANK YOU
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND I GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP
I'M SORRY SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. AB TWENTY TWO THIRTY
THREE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
PETRIE-NORRIS I GENEROUS AYE
PATTERSON. PATTERSON MONNING
GRAY I. LACKEY NOT VOTED. MEDINA. RODRIGUEZ AND WILSON RIGHT.
BILL SELF FIVE ZERO THAT BELL IS
OUT AND THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THANK YOU MEMBERS. ALL
RIGHT AND THAT THAT CONCLUDES
THE BUSINESS OF THIS MORNING'S
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE-
WE ARE ADJOURNED.